Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésor, on est toujours à Berlin
Regardez-moi ça,
On est sous un pont caché, déguisé en travailleur.
Ouais, un nouveau spot, on va tenter ça, on va voir ce que ça donne, il y a deux ponts en plus.
On est toujours avec Wim et Timohdie qui a déjà jeté l'aimant, prêt comme jamais.
What a... Oh! A frame? Non? Non? What the fuck?
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
Oh! It's dirty.
Yeah, it is.
C'est sale.
Ok, un parasol, c'est un parasol.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Un pied de parasol.
Yes.
A beautiful one.
Un très beau, oui
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Attention.
What?
Dans le parasol.
Tu vois ce que c'est ?
Non.
And roller skates.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
Oh man, yeah.
C'est joli.
Il y a des choses?
Ouais, j'ai pas lancé loin, j'avais des nœuds, mais j'ai peut-être quelque chose quand même.
Ouais, des pièces, non?
Oui, des pièces.
Ah oui, quand même.
Ok, ça se lève.
J'ai déjà senti ce truc, il se levait et il lâchait.
Oh, un seau.
Il est bien dégeulasse
Il est superbe.
Magnifique.
Bravo.
Merci
C'est un bon début
Ouais, ouais.
Bon début, hein.
Très bon début.
Le fameux couteau, arme de meutre
Bravo.
Ok.
Ok, ok.
Réveillez-vous tout le monde
Abonnez-vous
Un réveil.
Bravo.
Regardez ce que je viens de trouver.
Un original zippo.
On n'a pas encore tenté, mais il faut savoir qu'il nous arrive assez fréquemment de repêcher des zippos
et que ceux-ci sont censés être garantis à vie.
Donc on pourrait les renvoyer.
On va essayer de tenter d'expérience avec celui-là.
Genre?
Si, on s'en prend.
Yes.
Goute là
Tu le sais
We call it.
Sent, sent
It's ok.
Please do.
Impossible de le gouter
Un citron
Regardes ce qu'il y a dedans
C'est l'incensuré peut-être.
C'est de la sorcellerie
Yes.
Du Vaudou
With pepper.
Ah, il y a du piment, regardez.
Avec un citron et un mot.
Est-ce que c'était une photo?
Photo?
Ah, oui.
C'était surement une photo de la personne.
Oui, j'ai vu votre vidéo avec la photo
Oui, peut-être.
Oui, une photo.
Oui, c'est bon, j'ai annulé le sortilège
C'est pour avoir une érection.
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
Oh non, un caddie
Pas ça.
Oui, c'est un petit
Heureusement.
Regardez ce qu'il vient de trouver.
C'est un jouet
Oui, c'est un jouet
Ah, c'est cool.
Oui, aujourd'hui.
Bien joué.
Il y a quand même des munitions à blanc.
Il y a du 9mm à blanc.
Ça, c'est intéressant.
Allez, on a quelque chose.
Oh, une pince.
Oh non, elle est cassée.
Elle est cassée.
Petite pince.
Alors là, je viens de trouver ce cadenas qui a été fracturé.
Donc, c'est bon signe.
Encore une fois, c'est récent.
Ça montre qu'il y a des objets récents avec ça.
Ça a peut-être déjà été fait, mais...
Il se remplie de nouveau
Et là, j'ai ça.
On aurait dit un chargeur, mais non, je ne crois pas.
Ouais, c'est juste du métal.
OK, on continue.
Regardez ce que j'ai trouvé, les enfants.
England.
Actions, England.
Donc, c'est des menottes anglaises.
Oh, un téléphone.
Un téléphone fixe
Allô, Timothy.
England.
OK, nice man.
Elles sont ouvertes, c'est cool
Mais je n'ai pas les clefs
Non, c'est pas un problème.
C'est bon pour les filles.
Oui, pour les filles.
Pour  les fans de Timodhie
C'est ça, c'est bien.
Tu sais, je n'ai jamais vu ça.
Non, non.
Je pensais que c'était des policiers, parce que c'était comme ça.
Mais peut-être, l'England...
Oh, et on...
On les met et on...
Mais c'est toujours drôle.
C'est toujours drôle.
C'est trop drôle.
OK, c'est terminé.
C'est terminé.
Tu peux rentrer tranquillement si tu attaches Quentin
Oui.
Belle trouvaille, tu peux la garder
La petite cabane qui fait plaisir
Regardez quand même cet endroit.
En plein berlin.
Les amis Hollandais qui pêchent déjà
On a fait ce côté du pont.
On va passer de l'autre.
Et Quentin est encore en pleine forme.
J'aurais pu faire tomber la GoPro.
C'est vraiment super beau.
Voilà le look.
Là, c'est le look.
Après 4 heures de roadtrip
et 6 heures de pêche à l'aimant.
On est comme ça.
Après, on est encore déguisé en travailleurs.
Avec 4 jours de roadtrip.
C'est ce que je dis ?
T'as pas dit 4 heures ?
Non, j'ai dis 4 heures de pêche à l'aimant.
Pas mal alors, pas mal.
On ressemble à rien dans Berlin.
En plus, ils sont tous très bien habillés.
Et nous, on a de la boue sur le visage.
Totalement improbable.
On aura bien mérité une petite pause après ça.
Un bon repas.
On a changé de côté du pont.
Et j'ai un vélo.
On va attendre un peu qu'il se vide.
C'est un bon vélo
Il est encore parfait
Les pneus sont gonflés.
Quentin va surement faire un tour avec
Hé ouais, c'est déjà pêché ici.
C'est dommage.
Parce que c'était un très bon spot.
C'est pas souvent le cas en vidéo
Mais aujourd'hui, je suis vraiment crevé
C'est dur de continuer.
C'est la fatigue après tout ce road trip.
Baptiste il continue, mais doucement.
Parce que j'appâte
Ouais, ouais.
C'est pas du try hard là.
Regarde, regarde.
Regarde, c'est pas du try hard.
Un ballet.
Un ballet nickel.
Voilà.
Pour nettoyer le spot.
Ouais, pas bête.
Sympa, sympa.
Et les hollandais, pareil.
Il fatigue un peu, hein.
Tu sais comment on reconnaît un pêcheur à l'aimant français en Allemagne ?
Non.
The yellow jacket.
Et là, c'est orange.
C'est noir, oui.
C'est un black jacket.
T'as un très beau maquillage.
Voilà.
Good sign.
Quand tu trouves une arme
That's good, that's good.
Quand il trouve une arme, il se fait le maquillage.
Dernier côté du pont.
On est prêt.
Il y a un peu plus de pièces de ce côté.
Donc soit c'est moins pêche, soit il jette plus, soit...
Soit ça veut rien dire, mais c'est quand même bon signe.
Donc on va voir ce qu'on arrive à sortir.
Plus de pièces aussi, hein.
Ouais.
Gardes les, mets les de côté.
Pour le parking.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Wow, la quantité de pièces encore.
T'as vu la pile ?
Ouais, c'est une pile.
Ah non, il n'y a pas énormément de pièces, mais...
Elles sont en bon état cette fois-ci.
Et ça, c'est quoi comme pièce ?
Deux.
Alors là...
Je pense qu'on vous dira ça après.
Maybe Russian ?
Ruisse.
Je ne sais pas.
Cyrilliques ?
Mon œil est mauvais, mec.
Oh, un couteau
Suisse, non, non.
Oui, oui, oui.
Couteau Suisse détruit.
Et encore plein de pièces.
Enfin, plein.
Deux.
Deux centimes.
Et cinq centimes.
Ah, j'ai déjà trouvé un bout comme ça
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
Ah ouais.
Bien joué.
Un trousseau de clefs
Avec un badge.
Ok.
Ouais !
2 euros.
Comme toi
Ça fait plaisir.
Dans la poche
Baptiste a trouvé comme un jouet
Je crois que tu le mets sur une toupie.
Une toupie, c'est une toupie.
English or French ?
Vous avez fait des découvertes ?
Des découvertes ? Oui de bonnes découvertes
Comme elle
Oui.
Elles viennent d'Angleterre
D'Angleterre ?
Oui.
Oh, mon Dieu.
De vieux téléphones
Batteries.
Des munitions de la guerre
Ah, c'est vrai.
Oui, oui.
Vous avez un aimant ?
Magnet fishing.
Oh.
Non.
C'est du fer
De la pure fonte
Oh, yes.
C'est lourd
Bon, alors l'Allemagne, à part la pluie ?
Franchement, ça va, mais le temps, c'est vraiment terrible.
Tout le temps, c'est infernable.
C'est très propre
Et je pense qu'il y a quelques pêcheurs aussi.
Et regardez, j'ai vu la pièce de 2€ et j'avais même pas vu ça.
Et il y a une pile aussi, donc ça, c'est une bonne dépollution.
On met tout ça de côté.
Une mini lampe dynamo
Ah, ouais, sympa.
Ouais, je vois les quelles c'est
Bien joué.
OK.
Ah, non.
Oh.
Beaucoup de coins.
Oui, je les gardes pour me porter chance
Ah, OK, OK.
Ah, c'est possible de trouver une vieille arme
Oui, c'est possible.
Il y a un coin là-bas.
Les gens marchent et jettent dans le coin
Ouais.
Moi, je vais friser
Mais après, on peut pas faire ça en été, je pense, pour le coup.
Non, ben...
Il y a trop de monde.
Mais bon, je vais friser là, c'est pas bon.
Ah ouais, c'est bon.
OK.
Qu'est-ce que tu nous trouves ?
Oh !
Non, c'est encore de la fonte
Ah, c'est ça !
C'est ça !
Ah putain.
Mais là, je vais encore avoir plein de pièces mon petit Quentin
Moi, j'en vais plus tôt.
Ah ouais ?
Vas-y, on va regarder.
Celui qui a le plus de pièces, il paie l'apéro.
Oh, tu as...
Portable ?
Yeah !
Vieux.
Dorot !
Dorot, hein.
Je crois que c'est la marque de téléphone pour les personnes âgées.
Ah, c'est bien.
Moi, j'ai une pile.
Du coup, on n'a pas trop de pièces, mais voilà.
T'as gagné.
J'ai gagné ?
Ouais.
Thanks.
En plus, j'ai des pièces, quand même, hein.
Un beau 5 centimes tout neuf.
Ah, Rasta le pauvre, il est dans la voiture.
Ouais.
Ah ouais, d'ailleurs, il n'y a pas Rasta dans cette vidéo.
Il est en train de dormir.
Ouais, il dort, ouais.
On a déjà pêché ce matin.
Ouais, ce matin, il était avec nous.
Allez voir la première vidéo, si vous ne l'avez pas vu, à Berlin,
Elle vaut le détour
Elle est totalement dingue.
Et oui, donc Rasta dort dans la voiture
Il n'y a pas de risque.
Là, il pleut.
Et il est en train de se faire sa meilleure sieste.
Je pense qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'une belle surprise.
Encore une pile ?
Ouais.
C'est un peu inquiétant.
Il y a quand même des pièces aussi.
OK.
Une pièce qui sauve l'honneur, mais à part ça,
c'est pas glorieux.
Voilà.
C'est la fin de cette pêche allemande à Berlin, sous ce pont
Donc, pas d'armes encore.
Ouais, rien d'incroyable
On va continuer demain la mission Luger
Ouais, on continue à Berlin.
Nos amis seront de retour en Hollande dès demain.
Hélas ils ne pourront plus pêcher avec nous.
Ils vont prendre la route.
Un grand merci en tout cas d'être venu.
Merci.
Et allez voir la chaîne.
See you soon.
À bientôt.
On espère que vous avez apprécié cette vidéo.
Pour nous, le roadtrip en Allemagne continue.
N'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur Insta
pour plus de photos exclusives du voyage.
Regardez, le seul bâtiment de Berlin,
qui n'est pas tout propre,
ils ont laissé les plantes.
C'est original.
Tu fais du repérage de spots?
Si je jete l'aimant là, je trouve un Luger
Non, non, mais regarde les barres de fer
Peut-être qu'il y en a pas en dessous.
Je pense que si